bah ça c'est le trou voilà le trou par
leur lequel la grenade est passée ma vie
est chamboulée il faut que je me dise
qu'il ya des choses que je pourrais plus
faire
j'ai mal tous les jours un mollet je
reste pénalisée quotidiennement
[Musique]
on était des citoyens en colère on
venait quand même manifester
je viens parce que je n'en peux plus au
début on est sorti pour ça il le gilet
jaune était juste une marque de repères
tout a très bien commencé la
manifestation a commencé a donc à se
déplacer ensuite les forces de l'ordre
ont commencé donc à essayer un peu de
nous pousser ou de nous diriger
donc on a commencé à être plus ou moins
gazés et puis là d'un coup au bout de
honnêtement une demi heure de début de
manifestation ben j'ai entendu un gros
clash
j'ai senti un éclat dans ma jambe droite
dans mon mollet droit
j'ai dit à mon mari tout de suite que
j'étais touché
[Musique]
donc j'y arrive aux urgences et puis on
a commencé à essayer faire les soins
pour moi bêtement c'était donc juste en
fait l'impact du galet de la grenade de
désencerclement on va me dire vous
pouvez rentrer et vous inquiétez pas
vous aurez un cours de maths au mais
vous pouvez rentrer et suite à ça on m'a
dit donc j'ai fait une radio et on m'a
dit que j'avais quelque chose dans le
mollet et que je devais me faire opérer
que je pouvais pas rentrer chez moi
directement
c'était pas un galette d encerclement
n'a dit qu'elle est la ferraille dedans
on sépare galets quand vous à vos tirs
et m'a dit c'est la tête
si la taille du déclencheur
[Musique]
et on m'a dit que c'était les talons m'a
dit que c'est pour ça que c'est la
police un souvenir positif judiciaire
qu'il récupère
[Musique]
on m'informe que ma plainte
ils peuvent aller elle aura pas de suite
parce que tout simplement ils n'arrivent
pas à identifier le crs ou le gendarme
mobile qui a une qui est à l'origine du
tir de grenade et ensuite on me fait
donc comprendre que de toute façon
j'étais j'avais pas un tas dans cette
manifestation et que je fais partie des
peines perdues
déjà vous hésité à porter plainte parce
que c'est porter plainte contre un
policier et ben on m'a fait rentrer à la
maison
j'ai mal tous les journaux mollet il ya
des choses que je peux plus faire je ne
peux plus courir
je veux plus faire l'un des sports au
style tennis je travaille en maison de
retraite
j'ai pas le choix lui dit quand je
rentre le soir j'ai mal
on a deux enfants en pleine force de
l'âge mais il ya parfois des moments où
maman est fatiguée maman elle peut pas
le faire moi j'imagine qu'à 60 ans
j'aurai un déambulateur ou je battrai
[Musique]
sont capables de trouver des
manifestants qui lançaient un caillou
qui met le feu à une poubelle
mais après ils n'arrivent pas à
retrouver un crs je me sens victimes je
faisais rien de mal j'étais là pour me
dire que j'étais pas d'accord pour dire
qu'on n'en peux plus j'ai jamais rien
fait de mal j'ai toujours respecté que
ce soit la loi j'ai toujours émis 12
points de permis g j'ai peur
[Musique]
désolé moi je paye mes impôts je paye
mon loyer jeu qu'on travaille avec mon
mari tous les jours on ne vit pas dead
mais c'est dur on continuera la
manifestation s'il le faut avec la peut
soit mais mes idéaux de ne pas changer
je regrette pas tout ce que j'ai fait
donc je considère qu' il faut continuer
je suis gilet jaune je le resterai
mais j'ai peur parce que maintenant on
est des cibles